I'm so full
but I can't stop now
hey everyone my name is Matt Bell si and
this is whine about it a weekly video
series where I get drunk at my desk and
complain about stuff and on this very
special holiday edition
our topic is ways to win at Thanksgiving
dinner because Thanksgiving is more than
just a holiday it is a test of spirit
and I'm not about to lose this [ __ ]
so let's drink can't spill on my fancy
sweater
I'll pay 40 bucks for this sweater can't
we ruin it alright first Thanksgiving
rule number one if you stop eating after
one plate you are losing the food on
your plate should be one mountainous
heap of glory and if you stop at one
food Mountain you've given up
you think the pilgrim stopped at one
food Mountain they didn't the pilgrims
didn't stop for anything but they
probably should have because they killed
a bunch of people second Thanksgiving is
not a time for a chili
Thanksgiving is a time for dip and
everything in gravy and just sliding it
right down there everyone's always like
Matt why don't you slow down we can hear
you struggling to breathe this turkey
didn't sacrifice his life for me to slow
down this turkey sacrificed his life so
I could take his left leg dip in some
sweet mashed potatoes then shove it
right past my tonsils what's the take it
slow next every time you're drunk racist
uncle mentions Donald Trump take one big
deep breath and then scream violently
into the soft comfort of a warm butter
potato roll racist uncles can't ruin
your Thanksgiving if you're screaming
into a warm butter potato roll Donald
Trump can't find you there either just
scream it out that's what
also every time someone mentions that
they're having a [ __ ] baby or getting
married or they got a job promotion take
a big old shot of gravy cuz I'd rather
my arteries clogged up right now than to
list and do a list of your [ __ ]
accomplishments for a single second
guess what I did this year give nothing
you you're me bragging about it I'm not
here to hear about your [ __ ] life I'm
here to eat until I can't see colors
anymore next unless a salad is creamy
buttery and cheese based it has no place
getting stuffed in this go it give it
someone a salad on Thanksgiving is like
punching a baby right in its baby face
it might make you feel good but there's
a chime in a place this is Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving is a time for family and
friends and swallowing foods they're
made up of at least 50% mayonnaise now
for your [ __ ] salad I'll tell you
that also every time someone asks if
you're dating anybody just me out like a
hungry cat they're always like Matt
how's work how's your apartment are you
seeing anybody I'm always like next do
not under any circumstances announce to
the internet that you think your cousin
is hot if you're thinking about
announcing to the internet that you
think your cousin is hot log off take a
good hard look look in the mirror and
then never procreate with anybody
related to you or otherwise next
Thanksgiving is the only time of the
year where is acceptable to wear gym
shorts because eating is the only sport
worth sweating for I walk in that feast
and I'm ready to throw down and get rekt
also remember anything is a napkin if
you try hard enough all right it'll come
to you where do you need it finally if
anybody stops you from having the best
Thanksgiving of your life you just be
like one of those floats and the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade fat happy
and blissfully unaware of all the crazy
[ __ ] screaming around to you
that's how I spend my Thanksgiving just
floating around all the food just float
around stuff in my face well everybody
screams that's how I do it
all right everybody thank you for
watching this week as always you can
find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com and my page
which is facebook.com slash BuzzFeed
match and you can find our videos on
YouTube at BuzzFeed beta-gal and that's
everything that's over thank you for
watching have a [ __ ] happy turkey day
gobble gobble
eating lunch before me this was bad idea